[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings we're at a
crucial moment in the crisis over
ukraine the president met with his
national security team over the weekend
and vice president harris spoke with
ukraine's president in germany u.s
intelligence believes the kremlin has
now given russian troops orders to
proceed mr biden has agreed to meet with
president putin if russia does not
invade we're joined now by president
biden's national security adviser jake
sullivan jake good morning
good morning
so as you know president biden met with
his national security council yesterday
you were in that meeting can you share
with us the results
well president biden convened that
meeting in order to prepare a response
should russia
actually move forward and invade ukraine
and he's been clear all along throughout
this crisis that the united states and
its allies are ready either way we're
ready to continue diplomacy including at
the highest levels to try to resolve
this matter peacefully but we are
equally ready and we are united as the
west in imposing swift and severe
consequences if russia chooses to move
forward
and yesterday president biden got a
briefing on the details and the final
plans for those consequences should
russia move in the coming hours or days
yesterday on face the nation jake the
russian ambassador said listen there are
no such plans for an invasion which is
so confusing because you know when
you're a little kid and they say if it
walks like a duck sounds like a duck
looks like a duck it's a duck it seems
like we're just waiting for something to
happen can we be more proactive here
well first we have been very proactive
in laying out for the world precisely
what russia's plans and intentions are
and how they intend to put them into
motion and last week at the u.n security
council secretary blinken spoke to the
world and he warned the world that
russia would try to manufacture a crisis
in the conflict-stricken portions of
eastern ukraine that's exactly what
happened over the weekend he warned that
the russians would then make a show of
big meetings in moscow and in fact
that's exactly what's happening today
with president putin convening his
national security council so what we
have done is indicate to the world that
this is not something russia has been
provoked into this is a brutal war of
choice
that russia will be perpetrating on its
neighbor and that will enable enable us
if they in fact do move forward to rally
not just the west but the world to hold
russia accountable for what it has done
and then finally in terms of being
proactive we have moved thousands of u.s
troops to poland and romania and other
parts of europe in order to ensure that
every inch of nato territory is defended
against any further russian aggression
that goes beyond ukraine
jake the president said the military
will not help evacuate americans from
russia or ukraine what is the biden
administration doing
to help ensure that americans can leave
those countries safely and quickly if
needed
well part of the reason we went out
early and very clearly and said to
american citizens in ukraine it's time
to leave now
is to give them as much opportunity to
take advantage of commercial options air
and rail and road to get out of ukraine
to get home or to get to other parts of
europe more than 10 days ago
we indicated to them that they should
leave in the next 24 to 48 hours we have
continued to say that every single day
and we hope that americans will make the
responsible choice
and jake before you go can you help the
american people understand why we should
be concerned about this this country
people are looking at covert they're
looking at rising prices they're looking
at you know the gas is high the food is
high why should we be
why should we pay close attention to
this why does this matter to us
we have seen before how a small war in
europe can grow if we don't stand up in
strong and resolute terms to defend our
allies and partners that's why president
biden has sent troops to nato territory
not to fight russia and ukraine but to
defend nato and that has helped keep the
peace over the course of the past seven
decades in europe kept a major power war
between the u.s and russia from
happening i think it matters and it's
the basic value of freedom of choice and
freedom of destiny for all people
everywhere that's deep in the american
dna and that's why we support the
ukrainian people in this time
all right national security advisor jake
sullivan thank you so much we appreciate
you